well the first woman to accuse
Virginia's lieutenant governor of
misconduct is expected to speak in
public tonight for the first time since
her story came out
Vanessa Tyson says Democrat Justin
Fairfax forced her to perform a sex act
in 2004 he says it was consensual at
O'Keefe is outside Virginia's Capitol
building in Richmond
Edie we've been keeping you busy with
all of these headlines coming out
you sure have bianna continues that
accuser dr. Vanessa Tyson is scheduled
to appear to Stanford University event
later today long scheduled about the me2
movement she is one of two women who've
accused Lieutenant Governor Justin
Fairfax of sexual assault allegations he
strongly denies the two accusers both
say any delay to potential impeachment
proceedings only allows them to be quote
further victimized Fairfax push through
on Monday and seemed to successfully
avoid impeachment proceedings at least
for now Democratic delegate Patrick Hope
who had planned to file articles of
impeachment said yesterday there are
additional conversations that need to
take place before anything is filed even
as he plans to stay in office however
four of Fairfax's aides have quit
because of the scandal a sign that his
inner circle is shrinking Fairfax is due
back here in a rainy Wichman later today
and of course remains in the line of
succession if for some reason the
governor Ralph Northam suddenly decides
to step down amid calls to do so after
the revelation of that racist photo in
his medical school yearbook but some
african-american leaders are standing by
the governor saying they have quote
chosen to forgive John all right ed
O'Keefe thanks ed